foreign
David is calling from Saigon Vietnam I
think that's my first call from Saigon
in 30 years David how are you hi I'm
good thanks how are you good what are
you doing in Saigon
um uh living abroad I've been living my
wife and I have been living abroad for
about 16 years but our investments and
properties are in the U.S cool what do
you do for a living
uh International Educator
okay I teach the teacher yeah I was
going to say that sounded a lot like art
vandelay's importer exporter from
Seinfeld I've got a nice I'll actually
have a good friend whose brother lives
in Saigon that is in your business and
I'm wondering if you're him anyway yeah
all right go ahead brother how can we
help maybe I know him
um well um okay we uh we're big fans of
the baby steps we've we've done them all
we've done them all except for one and I
might get in trouble from you on this
one and that is that we have two rental
properties that um that are turning um a
profit and we don't want to pay off the
rest of the mortgage because we feel
like we're making more having that money
invested in the market
so and I know you uh with your baby
steps you um highly I recommend paying
off those mortgages or thinking why do
that if we can make more if that money
is in the market
can you share your wisdom oh you want to
know why I said that oh I see okay how
much money how much money do you have in
Investments
uh a little over a million good for you
well done how old are you
uh 57. excellent and how much are these
mortgages
uh they're about 170 each so 340 knocks
it out and that leaves you with 660 in
your investment if we use that
investment to Google to do that okay is
that right
uh yes okay and so really what we're
discussing is how much more you would
make on three hundred and forty thousand
over the interest
on the houses okay now here's the thing
um
I first approached this through the lens
of faith it was my first approach
because I have all the letters and
licenses after my name the academic crap
that says I'm supposed to know something
about money but I went broke so
apparently I did something wrong
um and I and so I discovered uh common
sense and what the Bible says about
money and I can't find anywhere as a
Christian this is my my journey not
yours okay I can't find anywhere in the
Bible ever that says anything positive
about debt it's not a Salvation issue
you're not going to hell because you
have debt it's not a God loves you less
if you have that it's all negative
though
the borrower is slave to the lender and
it goes on and on and on and on and on
all the negative references from that so
as as part of my faith walk I had to say
Okay God must know something or that I
don't understand about debt because I
was taught if you can borrow money at
um you know three four five percent on
your mortgage and you can invest it in a
mutual fund and make 10 or 12 then
you're making that spread that Arbitrage
which is what you're discussing correct
yes exactly now as I've gone forward
what I've discovered is that the vast
majority of wealthy people that we've
studied
uh people of Faith or otherwise have
avoided debt and gotten out of debt and
uh and have stayed away from it and I
kind of had to stop and go why is that
and I find very few people now you're
not highly leveraged but I find very few
people that are highly leveraged that
actually survive the people that borrow
money like crazy to buy rental
properties and doing Airbnb and all this
crap they're all broke in 10 years I
went broke doing that within within 10
years and so you can't find someone
that's been doing that for 20 years and
survived one of these economic Cycles
takes their head off
and so what that means is that debt
equals risk more debt equals more risk
and I think we can all agree to that can
you
uh yes yeah you have a little you have a
small amount of debt so it doesn't feel
like a lot of risk it's not as much risk
as if you had 3.4 million agreed
correct yeah yeah that's all I'll say
that more debt is more risk less debt is
less risk zero debt is approaching zero
risk and the only thing the only math
formula I have found that adjusts for
risk does not exist in the real estate
world it's only in the investment world
and we adjust for risk using the math
formula of a beta a beta is the height
of a uh if you do Peaks and valleys of
an investment it goes up and down up and
down up and down the the difference in
the Val the difference in the peak and
the valley is called a beta you're and
it's your the higher beta is a higher
volatility a a steeper mountain and a
more often cycle does that make sense
yes and in the investment world we use a
beta the higher the beta the higher the
risk because the more volatile it is and
we use an inverse relationship in the
math meaning you drop it under the
denominator and get nerdy here but the
that gives you the ability to calculate
risk into the investment and measure a
risky investment against a not so risky
investment that has a lower beta and
you've you've neutralized for risk
therefore you can compare Them Apples to
Apples we don't enter risk into the
formula that you used to tell me you
wanted to keep your debt if we put risk
in that formula and you do have some
risk not as much as if you had 3.4
million but if we put a low beta in your
formula it starts to neutralize into a
way with all your spread the other thing
that happens is when you don't have any
payments you just straight up sleep
better
that's true and I've done a high and
I've done detailed research 100 of the
foreclosures occur on a house with a
mortgage
and so I I would tell you this let's do
this you can try this if you want to I
would pay them both off
and if you hate it
go get you another mortgage later
okay
um okay fair enough uh can I ask you
another question a follow-up question
Matt so you should be scared to after
that long answer but yeah
back in stats class all that money out
we're gonna pay we're gonna pay through
the nose and taxes pulling it all out of
all of our uh our retirement investment
how old are you so it's like oh you're
57 no I would not take it out of
retirement is it all in retirement
yeah this is all you don't have any
money that's not in retirement
we have yeah we have some how much we
haven't
um a couple hundred well I'd use that
then tada
yeah and you have a good income and I
would just no I'm not going to cash out
and pay penalties on your retirement I
was not suggesting that but because that
changes the formula now you may have
some capital gains on it and I I would
do that I have lived 100 debt free since
I went broke 30 something years ago and
I have had a wonderful life I've made a
lot of money I have a lot of Investments
and they're all paid for and when crap
happens like the Island of Misfit Toys
is misbehaving up in Washington DC right
now and they're screwing up the whole
freaking economy I'm sitting here
peaceful and slept really good last
night except that my four-year-old
grandson put a plastic snake under my
pillow but other than that I slept great
last night that really did happen good
for him uh I told him his new name is
Sneaky Snake I like it that's his new
nickname when he come when I go to his
rehearsal dinner in 24 years he's gonna
introduce her to the Sneaky Snake that's
it we'll throw that snake at him I'm
saving it